Hello Freak bitches.
It's kind of weird how it took a long time for three d me to come back.
I they think I really made it come back either.
Well Dude Avatar in my opinion,
the admitted combat and I saw it in imax three d that's like an experienced man.
I had a smile on my face,
that whole movie and when I heard all these people that were like,
oh the movies to the plot was very transparent and like oh my God,
shut up.
Shut up.
Stupid.
How could you not enjoy that?
Oh you're telling me the big blue aliens aren't real.
Whoa.
Get out of here
after Avatar.
People reporting depression like,
but yeah,
cause they liked our depression is a real thing.
Yeah,
it's a fucking is now there's no color and after Avatar.
I wonder how it's recognized.
I wonder if like psychologists are behind it as well.
You have avatar depression.
It sounds like you've got a bad case of Avatar to press.
That's not outside of the realm of possibility.
Oh I'm sure.
Yeah.
Well,
I know the depression that comes from playing a really awesome video game and
then going out into the world.
You know what I mean?
Like we were driving here and we'd go back,
we'd go by this mountain of rocks and he looks out the window and he goes,
oh,
that's like,
what does that look from our,
oh,
I'm like,
I don't even know what that means.
You have a fantasy environment.
What the fuck are you talking about?
Well,
I just got this Imac.
I just got this like giant Imac,
like the biggest monitor I've ever had.
So I was like,
well,
aren't those awesome?
I've got to see what works.
Suck.
Mine died today.
Yeah,
but it's probably just a hard drive.
No,
I hope not.
Oh God,
I'd got to back your shit up,
dude.
There are,
there are things back.
Not that,
not that computer,
because I use that computer just for audio,
like you know,
for podcasts and slap a fucking one terabyte drive on it and one time timeshare
full drives.
I just keep on running on of hard drive space.
Wow.
That's incredible.
Fucking sucks.
That shouldn't needs to go away.
What happened to,
I remember when I worked at gateway computers,
I don't know if we talked about it as anyway he's telling him come on,
design it back.
It is awesome.
I know you were saying that your shit died but it is awesome and what were you
going to say about that?
I was going to say it's like a fucking window and do an alternate universe.
When you've got a really good video game and you're looking at it,
it's like these,
I think the word video games,
you got to go down the tube is man because you,
you,
someone hears,
you say,
I love to play video games.
They're like you fucking nerd.
But it's like hey cause you know it's like what,
what it's turning into.
It's not really,
it's going to get to the point where it's not video games anymore where it's
something else.
Like I feel like it's like world of Warcraft,
starcraft,
all these like a portal.
What we're,
this is the very first surge of water and this virtual tsunami that's about to
come subjectively sweeping over everyone.
Because that thing you say about like maybe our neurology can't resist movies
cause it's so overpowering.
It's like I think that there's gonna be some truth to that
because these games are missing a few components and this is,
this is what I think of when I'm stoned playing world of Warcraft.
If I could smell like,
if there was a sense of smell involved in this and also they've made it,
there was a sense of like,
I mean it's,
they've made machines that do that and I don't think it's going to have to be a
mind thing.
It's a mind machine thing.
I think it's going to have to be,
so it's going to be a little stimulate some part of your mind.
Maybe you can wear some,
maybe everyone's going to have to shave their head.
Like real players.
The view,
you know,
you're going to have to do like a horizontal Mohawk thing real plus I,
you know like this dude's legit,
he doesn't give a fuck.
It was up to club,
but this big stripe shaved on his head and then you put this thing on skin to
skin on your head and it,
it has precise,
like you line it up on the video game,
it'll show you how to line it up with the exact cortex,
exact portion of your brain.
And then it sends signals that show you like burning,
meet,
smell,
and show you that.
And then,
but then you know what else it does while you're,
and this is really weird while you're playing the game and our races,
your memory of your previous life.
So the moment that thing goes on,
you'll have no more past your,
just the memories of the character in the game,
rushing through the game,
playing the game,
completely unaware of the fact that you used to exist as a person too.
And then you know what happens,
you're doing a podcast,
you're like,
oh fuck man,
my heart feels weird.
And you suddenly wake up and your futuristic apart and you're like,
ah man,
that game was awesome.
So right now we're playing a game.
Yeah.
Like,
yeah,
like that with a lot of people say this could be like some alien simulation,
you know that we're just an alien and involved in a really high powered super
advanced bad ass video game called planet experience.
The lives of billions of people all individually.
I wrote something once about maybe the life that we're living.
Maybe the reason why it seemed so fake is cause it is fake.
And what we are in is some sort of a reality simulation of the roaring twenties
of the technological age.
Like maybe we live in some time where everything is all scented candles and
perfectly lit white rooms and no one has a muscle car and no one's getting their
dick sucked.
And you know,
and maybe there's like a simulator that you can run when you run where it's just
chaos but chaos that's entertaining as fuck.
He's like every time you turn around there's some new thing Christina Aguilar
fucking up the national anthem,
2 billion people tuning into the wedding.
There's constant shit going on to keep you entertained and you are,
you are in this biological ride canister.
Yeah.
And you're going through this thing and you're in this,
you're the,
you're a portal to this ride is your skin and your flesh pops.
It pops through into this dimension and you know,
it sounds like you're advocating fantasy.
It sounds like you're advocating,
well,
you know,
so you want to look at your life as if it's some sort of a simulation.
Just live it as a simulation.
Yeah.
I'm saying yes I am.
Yeah,
why not?
Right.
It's very empowering.
Yeah.
I think the first person ever heard suggest that was Mckenna.
I think Mckenna was talking about you.
How did he say it?
He was,
and he was quoting someone else.
So I'm doing a third hand quote,
but he said you should view your life as he's,
say it
as a conspiracy or as view your life as it's as it's as if the world is run by a
select group of people and that group of people is you and your friends.
Yeah.
The,
your,
your somehow or another secretly in charge with running the world and running
the university and the most important things in the university.
She,
you and your friends cause it's the most empowering way to view the world.
Well yeah,
because what's the cause?
What's the other side?
The other side of it is this kind of like pseudo empathy for like strangers that
you don't know.
Like so many people wander through their day just frothing with terror or
whatever they've seen on the news.
And so for them the world's awful,
but then they're real situation is usually pretty good.
You know,
like the,
it's like a fucking,
uh,
Bill Hicks has that awesome joke about CNN,
CNN watch the news and then outside it's like beautiful and the grass is
growing.
So there's this mental pollution that comes pouring out of every information
device that we have.
And that like corrupts your mind and you begin to think you're in a horror story
when your real reality is one that's usually quite pleasant.
The,
that experience,
the [inaudible] experience,
the mushroom experience,
you know,
everybody,
everybody that is religious wants to believe in God.
What I'm telling you is I can show you something that represents God for sure.
You can meet what God is.
And I'm not saying it's God your meeting,
but you can meet what God is,
what God is is perfect and all knowing and all embracing and loving and wise and
and constantly around you all the time.
Well when you take mushrooms,
that's what you feel.
That's what you feel.
You really feel God.
And I'm not saying that it is God that you're communicating with or what God is
or what are the what even the concept of God.
When you say God,
all of a sudden it's this male hierarchy,
a point of you know,
point of reference where you think of like one alpha that controls all.
But it's not that God is more like everything I,
it's like a super dimensional glob of its efforts.
It's
an intelligence,
it's this,
it's always,
and also it's,
it's constantly changing.
That's the other thing like it's,
it's like trying to even talk about it.
It's like trying to talk about like a spinning slot machine.
It's like,
it's constantly like morphing and shifting and it's so fucking potent.
Whatever it is that we're runoffs of it.
Like when you see water running down your windshield and like,
streams of water will break into little globs of water.
That's what we are.
We're just little broken off globs of superintelligence that have taken on these
personalities and think that we're individuals and you know what else breaks off
in that
fucking thing?
Elves,
hyper dimensional things that aren't necessarily out to love you.
And like there really is like there are beings out there that are,
um,
I don't know man,
like superintelligent toddlers,
I think Mckenna talked about it.
They're like,
they're like baby God or something.
Okay,
here's the devil's advocate point of view.
Please.
How do you not know that those thoughts,
those demons just represent thoughts in your mind and perhaps what that
experience is entirely is you contacting your own thoughts and ideas and dreams
and hopes and expression without the context of reality attached to them.
Sure.
So without the idea of,
you know,
what you did that you're embarrassed about,
that made you weird about your underwear when you were 13 you know,
instead of that maybe it manifests itself in almost a living thing and almost a,
you know that project you're seeing these when you're saying you are beings out
there that are fucking with you,
maybe those are things that you've let grow in your mind.
Well yeah,
I mean I think that that's the modern take on it and I think that that's one
useful handle to like get her get,
get to,
to like grab a hold of an ideal.
I'd be considered that when you were in there,
when you,
you said you had an experience where like these are projection mechanisms but
this the yeah,
that what you're seeing literally is like that thoughts are live there.
They're real things that they look,
you ever heard the possibility,
I mean the discussion rather of the idea that aliens will come through the mind
and that they're not going to manifest themselves in a real form.
And that when you think of the imagination or when you think of dreams and what
we have is some weird,
slippery sort of experience that we can't completely control.
But what if that dimension of dreams,
that sleep dimension that you tap into when all your neurochemistry starts
flowing between the blood brain barrier while you're in heavy rem sleep,
what does that is in fact,
another dimension would have that is in fact a world.
And that is where aliens will contact you through.
They will contact you through this spiritual dimension instead of a physical
dimension.
Yeah.
Well,
if that's the case,
and if you think about taking mushrooms and these,
these l show up,
it is possible that negative things that you've created in your own life,
shitty choices or bad energy that you've set forth and then nurtured and and
repressed and put it down and tried to deny it and all these different things
that people do to sort of rationalize creepy things that they're doing in their
lives.
What if those things manifest themselves as living organisms in the free pool of
your mind?
Yeah.
You know,
that's actually,
I think fucking Carl Young said that exact same thing that you met Carl Young
this weekend.
I'm at a crazy guy who took ship 6.8 grams of mushrooms and told me he was Carl
Young.
This guy comes up to me and goes,
he goes,
I need to talk to you.
I have information that I'm sure you don't know about it.
I go,
how can you be sure?
And he goes,
I just know.
I tried to talk to Brian,
read Ben about it,
but he replied to my email with some stupid joke.
You go,
that sounds like Brian.
I want
to give you nuggets for that.
So that whole boy goes,
I really,
I've been doing psychedelic research.
I need to get this information for you.
I listen.
It's going to sound crazy.
I used to be in another life.
I was Carl Young.
I go,
how can you be sure?
And he goes,
I've seen things that you've never seen.
I go,
how can you know that this is ridiculous?
So you get to confidence on get out of here.
I remember that guy have is,
do you remember?
Yeah,
I got to find that email.
That's crazy.
I talked about them on the podcast,
on a plane with Sam Aaa.
I did.
But that podcast might suck.
I'm not even going to release it.
I might not release it because we were both hung over and tired and we're
talking about stupid shit.
So I'm not sure if I'm still hung over from fucking Joey Diaz giving me a banana
cake.
Yeah,
I got a text from Brian in capital letters do not eat.
Joey Diaz is banana bread.
You can never eat edible marijuana that Joey Dee has given.
Know as you have xenon hand,
don't take that list.
You have a fucking big hypodermic filled with adrenaline that you get stuff into
your chest.
Where vein?
Oh Dude,
you,
Joey Diaz gave me a,
um,
once gave me like some breath strips I guess is the first time I'd taken breath
strips and he was like,
eat two of these.
And I'm like,
no,
he really tell you,
hey,
I don't tell anybody ever detect more than a quarter.
I hold their hand.
I go,
dude,
listen to me Bro.
Listen to me.
I love you.
Don't take more than a quarter.
Joey likes the tour knowing Joey Diaz.
That's what I did.
I only took half of one of these knowing him and I was driving home on the
interstate and uh,
was like,
well it's,
it's definitely the apocalypse world is ending.
I see that clearly now.
I'm when the last days and uh,
and um,
there was a McDonald's and I was going to stop my car and to the Mcdonald's to
get a burger because traffic wasn't moving.
That's how bad the logic was working in my mind.
I just get a fucking,
I know I can make it there to get a diet coke and back.
But anyway,
I get home,
I'm having the most terrible marijuana trip.
I'm laying in bed.
I'm like,
oh my God,
the world's in my heart's pounding phone rings,
phone rings,
Joey Diaz,
I answered.
He's like,
welcome to my house mother fucker.
So he's thought you took all two of them.
He knew the number you're going to get a quarter.
Yeah.
Fuzzy.
Just surmise that he's so crazy.
My best buddies got the little Listerine,
the acid thing and there was like a few of them in there and I guess they all
melted together.
Do you remember that?
I did that.
I did that once and the guy took like a bunch of them ever did.
He never smoked weed.
You never eat wheat.
And he was like as first time trying it.
So Joey,
you know,
gave him some,
and there was like a lot in there and they had melted together into one and you
got a massive panic attack.
I think the guy called an ambulance call called nine one one you had a panic
attack.
Yeah,
we'd see.
That's the thing,
man.
There needs to be a special nine one one like when you press a button on your
phone,
when you get directed,
like,
have you eaten edible marijuana?
Press Cherry Garcia.
Somebody can calm you down.
Yeah.
Okay.